[Music]
this is welcome
tyson barrett
thank you this is the corner room right
so we have to
everyone leaves and comes at weird times
if you're here for doing learn about
list columns and data table
you're in the right place or maybe you
want to see
julie's and allison's beautiful artwork
you're also in the right place maybe you
just heard that i had a few
data table hex stickers they're really
rare in the wild
i do have like two more so
come find me um in any case whatever
brings you here welcome
uh our studio comp is one of my favorite
things in the world i have to say that
very
carefully it's one of my favorites
because i think
my wife and kids are watching that
just to be clear they are my favorite
our studio is closed
um okay so if this is you
where you look at the tivers code and
you're like wow that that is beautiful
but then you also feel this when you
look at data table code
i understand nothing that that is okay
that is expected for this audience for
the most part i know a lot of people
have used data table
however my goal today is to show how the
tivers
and data table are complementary and
to show that i'm going to show it using
list columns and and how they're
beneficial and how you can use them in
data table
so to start what even is a list column
i'm curious how many have purposefully
used a list column
in their work oh you guys are awesome
that it's about half that's awesome so
for those that haven't a list column is
basically where you take
some subset of the data either a vector
or a data table
or there's a bunch of other things you
can put in there
and you group them into a single column
so this example shows we have this data
and then we nest it there's a group nest
function in
d plier and essentially what it does is
it grabs
all the data that's associated with
group one and shoves it right here into
a single cell
what's cool about this is you can put
all sorts of stuff in here you can put
expressions you can put visualizations
like
ggplot code all that stuff can go into a
listcomb
but you may be wondering like why would
you want to do that that that is weird
uh that that's at least my first
impression when i saw this column was
like you just
you just can't stop can you you just
always want to add something new
but really it is a great question why
would we want to use this
i've compiled a short list of some some
of the reasons
the first is that there are several
functions in the tidy verse which means
it must be cool
so that's one reason to learn it i'm
going to show today
that it can make some data manipulations
actually safer
you can avoid some common problems by
using a list column
it's also memory efficient so if you're
working with really big data
a list column can reduce redundancies in
your data
and in some cases it can even make
understanding what you're looking at
your data much simpler when your data is
really complex
and the last reason i had was it just is
going to show up
if you've ever used something like
benchmark uh
it's there and you can't avoid them
they're just gonna show up in your life
so it's good to get to
know list columns a little bit
on the other hand a wide data table
we have tons of amazing tools especially
stuff that we've learned here
at our studio conf according to the
readme they give
these six uh reasons why
a data table is important i'm gonna
focus on these first three
uh the first one a concise syntax so
data table it's built up with these
parts right here you start with your
data table
uh so we'll call it dt for for short and
in the square brackets you have three
main parts there's other parts that you
can use but there's three
main ones there's i j and by
so to translate that after talking about
translating
into deployer verbs
i you can think of that as either a
filter or
a range so the things that you would
normally put in those two
you would put an i in j
you can think mutate so when you see
code
in that place think mutate what would i
put in mutate
and then bi is like group i so i'm going
to show some examples that highlight
exactly what those look like but
whenever you're seeing
the ij by i often translate that in my
head to
filter or range mutate and group by
next thing is that it's really fast uh
that may be the only reason why
you're here is you heard that it's
really fast
responding to data tape wide data table
is so fast this is what i hadley i don't
know if you've
heard of him this is what he said i
think it's a relentless focus on
performance across the entire package
and i think this is true i've
contributed a little bit to the data
table package
and every time they
pause and look at anything that could be
slowing down your code
or using up extra memory and they do it
to a crazy degree
and it's really paid off the package is
incredibly fast
which also goes along with it being very
memory efficient
this was an analysis done by uh
matt dao the the creator of data table
this was with a huge data set
might not be huge to some of you if
you're working with
a lot of flowing data this one has a
billion rows and nine columns
uh it's about 50 gigabytes of memory
um he compared all these different
frameworks
and for the most part they either just
ran out of time
or couldn't even start
with data table it was able to
accomplish
a fairly complex summing by group
request in a reasonable amount of time
too
so because you have such a great
framework in the tivers and you have
such great performance in the data table
package i say let's team up
let's make them work together and so for
today's example
we're going to work with some some
grammar that's provided with the ty
versus
nest and nun-ness so nesting when you
think of that it's making a list column
of data tables or vectors or
visualizations unnest is unnesting those
list columns back into
what we normally think of in data frames
or data tables
so in order to highlight this i'm going
to go through a brief example
we're going to use data from statistica
and data from the d plier package of the
star wars
data so uh this has actually become
really common for me i start with
these two lines of code at the top of my
scripts
so i have the ty verse and data table uh
note that the approaches that i show you
today actually work
with the developmental version of data
table but there
are other ways of doing this this is
just the way that it's going to work
going forward so i want to present that
so the two data sets we're gonna play
around with
the d plier ones that top one it has the
name of the character
it has their species their home world
and then it has
oh no there's a list column it shows up
already so
we have films so it's a character vector
of the films that for example on the
first row that luke skywalker is in
it has five films uh listed
uh the other data set it's a revenue
data set and it's by film
so a new hope i made 775
million dollars roughly and you can
look through the rest when we get to
that so these two
if our goal is to understand how things
in the first data set relate to
revenue for the movies we're going to
have to do some work to get it in that
format
because right now we couldn't join these
very easily
so just to get us to where so we have a
framework we're working from
uh you are here at the tiding
and transforming steps of the data work
life
uh again this is from allison
beautiful just makes me happy looking at
it
so one of our issues right here that we
have to deal with is
that one of the data sets is at the film
level so we have per film the revenue
and the other one is at the character
level by character we have
information about them and so they're
not in a format that we can easily
join them so that we can look at things
together
so the first thing we're going to do is
a nest
so we're going to unnest the films
column
it's the again a list column of
character vectors
and so the first thing we're going to do
is we're going to let r know that we're
going to be using
data table this is one of the really
important steps to use in data table in
order for the square brackets to work
you have to tell our that's a data table
so in this one we're just grabbing it
straight from
the d plier package and we're just
letting it know that it's a data table
we'll call it sw here
and then this is where the un-nesting
happens so
if you remember what we were talking
about before you can look at the
placeholder so you have
a placeholder here for i in this case
we're not going to be filtering or
arranging so we just
leave that blank do a comma and then
this placeholder
is for like things that you would do and
mutate
here we're creating a new column
or in essence replacing it
by taking the the elements we're
unlisting here
in the currently list column
uh called films and then
we do in the by statement we're just
going to put all the other variables
that are at the character level that we
want to hold on to for example like name
and species
so this produces this data set so now
instead of just one luke skywalker
row and the
films being shoved into a single cell
now we have the name and we have
each film as a row
so we can see that luke was in revenge
of the sith return of the jedi etc
next um i propose that we actually do
another nesting so
we're not getting away from from the
list columns that easy so
we're going to create here a new column
called
data and what we're going to do is we're
going to
create a list column that's what this is
doing
of this symbol it's dot sd and if you
haven't used data table very much before
you can think of it as the subset
of the data so sd for subset of data
and in this case that subset's going to
be everything
that's not in the buy statement
so what does this produce
this so now by film
we have the associated data in a single
cell
so we have a new hope and all the data
that goes with the new hope
is now comfortably packed into that
single cell
as a data table
so now we actually can join them and i
suggest that this is a great way of
doing this
in data table one way to join is
you have one data table and then the
first
part of the square bracket and the i
part you actually put another data table
so revenue is another data table
and then you tell it what you're joining
on and this is a really
fast form of joining and when
you print this out this is what we now
have so we have per film we have the
associated data
and we have revenue so the reason why
i think nesting before we joined was
really useful
is has i don't know you don't have to
raise hands to admit it but
has anyone made a mistake joining data
or been surprised by the result
when you're joining data if so you're
human
i've done it numerous times and it's
usually like a misspelling and one of
the keys
there's there's a million ways that
things can go wrong when you're joining
data
and so one way to make it simpler is
actually using
uh this nesting and so all we had to
look for was
the key and anything that the new
dataset's bringing in and now
it's really easy to problem solve i can
look through if there was a surprise
or one the revenues wasn't there i would
be able to find out really quickly
whereas
if my data set was really long and not
nested
it would be much harder
so now that we have the data sets
together we actually can do some
analyses
here like i mentioned before all of this
happening here is mutate
but this time we have this what is
called the walrus operator
that's my favorite name for an operator
and you can see why it's called a walrus
operator right the
teeth so what it's doing
is it's creating a new variable called
counts
and it's reaching into each cell of data
that's a column that we have in our data
table
and we're using count to just get the
count
by each species in the data that we have
what this operator does that's different
than what
we're normally used to in our is that
it's going to modify
in place and this is a nuance that is
important when you start using
data table is it is changing
swn that object in place it's not making
a copy it's just
changing it right there and so you don't
actually have
uh any assignment towards the end of
this
this actually takes care of the
assignment which is
uh sometimes a hurdle for people to get
used to as they're
they're getting in there so this is
going to create a list column again
you but this time using per map uh of
counts by each when i have
an outdated thing there it it's by
species instead gender
you'll notice at the end of the object i
keep putting the square brackets
that forces the print in data table
there's
when you use this operator sometimes it
doesn't print
and so when you are using data table
this is a great way to force it to print
if you want it to
and now last step we're just about there
now we're going to un-nest a list column
that has
data tables in it or tibbles in this
case
instead of vectors so this time we don't
actually need to give it a name like we
did before
now we're just on nesting it so this is
the new variable
and we're just grabbing that and then
nesting by
film and revenue
and what this is going to do is it's
just going to grab everything in
each of those individual data sets and
it's just going to unnest it so it looks
like a normal
data table
so this is what we get we get for a new
hope
we can see the revenue that's tied to it
we can see that
there are three droids in a new hope
if you're familiar with the movies uh
you probably can list off what what
droids those are
for a new hope there's 12 humans etc
and from here we can get proportions and
things and we could
possibly come up with this and see how
revenue is associated with
how many the percent of the major
characters being human in a movie
the force awakens really throws things
off because that's the new one and made
a ton of money
but for the most part it looked like
people watched it less
if there were more humans we just like
we want other stuff
but at this point you're like okay cool
whatever like
uh we're here for the performance um
and it is actually kind of cool looking
at performance when you're working with
packages like this so i packaged up some
of these functions
to make them easier to to test and to
use it's in tidy fast if you're
interested it's on on github
and so for nesting this is a really
small data set
but you already start to see some some
improvement
the place that you see a lot of
improvement with nesting is the memory
that it uses to do the operation
so the the improvement in performance
both with memory
and time actually grows as your data set
gets bigger and bigger
and as you have more and more groups
so as your data gets more complicated
and bigger
the benefits grow for unnesting
similar thing you do see benefit even
with a small data set
but again it grows the the benefits grow
with the size of the data and the
complexity of it
so uh that's everything i have for you i
i hope you got to see a little bit how
data table can
be integrated into your work that it's
definitely not a replacement of anything
in duplier or vice versa
that they are very complementary
this is the the picture slide if you
want to find all the resources that are
tied to me
take a picture i'm really grateful for
the data table team
everything they've done and for julian
allison for letting me use their their
beautiful art thank you
thank you tyson
i think we have time for one or two okay
questions
um first one from william two asks
what did you use as data table rather
than
set dt uh so the set dt
will replace the object in place
and so when the data set's not
huge i recommend using the as.data table
because it creates a copy
and then you're not going to be
modifying your first object whatever
whatever that was before when your data
get really big and that you don't want
to make copies
then set dt is is the way forward i
think it's a great question
another one is what are
your next steps for tidy fast
so uh it's a great question
as of right now tidy fast is more trying
to implement
tidy r functions with data table as of
the back end because i didn't want to
even try to compete with something like
dt plier
it's a fantastic package so it's mostly
tidy r
functions mostly it's
testing bug fixing and and just
improving the package
and i have one last one here it's going
to be a quick one
favorite star wars character
[Music]
that is i i really fell for ray i think
rey is
is the the hero that we all have wanted
uh so yeah ray is my favorite thank you
jason appreciate it
you